。
嗯。
好，咱们准备开始上课吧。嗯，说一下这部电影啊，这部电影呢为什么选它呢？因为它确实是一部呃21世纪以来呃香港电影的一个高峰，甚至在香港电影史上都是拥有里程碑地位的一部电影啊啊，甭管你觉得它好与不好。你现在再去看，觉得它。
是不是有很多的瑕疵和bug，或者是像我说的，在制作上呢其实是相对粗糙的啊，但是它的地位是毋庸置疑的，它确实是香港电影的一个。
一个高峰应该客观的认识到啊，香港电影。
没有以前那么。
那么辉煌了。
主要是因为华语片市场啊不在。
都是他的天下。
方面是。
那个。
台湾片啊也起来了。另外更重要的当然是大陆片啊，大陆片也起来。
嗯。
以前是他一家独大啊，占领整个华语市场。
确实是有这样的优势啊。
一方面是市场优势。另外一方面呢他们是对外的一个窗口，接触西方的片子比较多，有时候直接汉化就可以就可以这个这个引领潮流，对吧？你像早期的香港流行音乐，由于因为音乐和电影一样啊，早期香港音乐也是控制着所有的华语市场。
那创作来不及怎么办呢？大量的从日本买版权是吧？买来版权直接就是配上词儿，就可以在华语市场赚很多钱。这个确实是这样啊，嗯同学们咱们做这一行，或者是你不管做哪一行，嗯，在理解一个市场的时候啊，都要有保证客保持一个客观的思维。
嗯，当然了，很多人就投入感情啊，说老师你说的不对，就是那一代人除了发哥、古天乐、刘德华、梁朝伟这样的人才是吧？现在没有这帮人才了。如果再有一帮这样的人才一样可以这个拯救整个呃香港内，这是一种。
意气用事的一种想法啊，其实不是的啊，我们还是要客观点讲，主要是市场不行的啊。来开始看片。对，呃，说到这个市场啊，很多同学刚才聊说呃喜欢看粤语版还是国语版的问题啊。我跟大家讲呃，在整个七八十年代的，我们这一批我们是听着粤语长大。
所以说整个七八十年代的北方小孩啊，特别是东北小孩儿，山东小孩这种北方小孩，我们这一代人都觉得粤语特别的酷。
我们甚至会以以以会唱粤语歌为荣是吧？你去跟北方大哥啊，70年代末8七八十年代的北方大哥一起去KTV，他绝对会拿不起话筒给你唱一首蹩脚的粤语歌。
确实影响了一代人啊影响了一代人香港的这个文化无间道啊，大家都很明确的知道他讲的故事是什么啊，但是我们也拉一下信息拍第一拍第三分钟，先用呃他先用一个简单的字幕点了一下题，就是这个无间啊无间道无间地狱的由来。
然后呢，因为是佛佛呃佛教的一些呃术语啊，所以带出一个寺庙的环境，寺庙的一个环境交代琛哥要在警察里安插一批卧底。
其中我们的这个主角啊，后面当然知道他是主角啊之一，刘建明就是其中一员啊，因为特写会给到那个陈冠新这张脸。刘建明是其中一员啊，实际上就是讲。
主角的一个登场啊，然后第二拍来到第5分钟啊，两个主角，两个主角在警校相遇，没有刻意的交代他俩人有交情，但是交代两个人的脸啊，这个陈冠希和于文乐。
命运的齿轮啊就开始转动了。其中呢。
阿仁啊阿仁。
嗯，也就是后来的梁朝伟这个角色啊，我们叫他阿仁。阿仁呢作为一个学长啊，学长应该是高一级啊，呃天分很好，被派去黑帮当卧底啊，也在警察部呢是一个被开除的一个假象状态。
然后呢嗯这里还有一个很重要的点题的一个戏。大家呃在开除这个阿仁的时候，对吧？教官问谁想跟他交换？
我们的另外一个主角，我们说这个故事，两个主角是镜面主角，同一个树枝上的两朵花。我们说两个镜面主角想交换身份啊想交换身份。
第三盘来到第六分第6分钟。
两个主角因为交代的是小时候的事情嘛，所以第三拍第6分钟开始，两个主角做了一个成长蒙太奇啊，分别怎么成长。在成长的过程中也偶然有交叉。比如说那个呃我们的刘警官曾经逮捕过二仁啊，但那都是小时候的事，然后通过一组成长蒙太奇。
两个人长大了啊，非常那个常用的处理方式，从这个我们说从优乐切成了梁朝伟，那个冠希哥切成了那个华华哥啊。
然后整个前史结束。
出片名。
前三拍以后，前十结束。
很重要啊，记没记得我说有些电影是真的有前史的。但是这个前史我们不列入。
前十我们不列入四幕，为什么呢？因为要进入第一幕的时候，会重新交代主角的现状和困境。自己给我记住啊，所有有前十的电影前十不需要进入四幕室，而且一般前十完了之后才出片名。
表示正式开始故事正式开始故事之后，由于那个前十真的就是个前史而已。所以要重新交代主角的现状和困境。甚至第一幕第一场戏就要给我交代主角的现状和困境。
好吧，进入正式进入故事啊，第四趴第8分钟，两个主角先做了一个相遇啊，先做了一个相遇。
两个人在音响店相遇，探讨音响的音色，这场戏相信大家非常熟悉，即便是没看过这个电影，也知道这场戏，对吧？
呃，再次强调两个主角，实际是同样的人啊，镜面角色。因为他们有共同的点，对音乐非常的爱好。我们说在一场戏里面，即便是单一推进的戏，我们也要做反转。这场戏呢里面也是有变化的。记没记得我给大家讲过单场戏的写法，里面要有变化和转。
你看这场戏上来是什么呢？上来是刘德刘警官来音响店买音响。然后呢，阿仁作为一个非常有经验的人给他推荐。
对吧。
但是到后期却发现。
刘警官实际上比阿仁更懂音响。
反而给阿仁推荐了一根线，阿仁还真的就信了他，所以从那个音响店顺走一根线，对吧？最后还有小的转折，就阿仁根本不是这家店的店主，他是来这个这个收保收护费的对吧？
我们说你看这个单场戏写的就非常完整，非常漂亮啊。第四趴。
这第四趴还有一个作用，交代的是阿仁的什么交代的是阿仁的现状，他是个黑社会收保护费的，同时也做了阿仁的救猫咪。
阿仁救猫咪是干什么啦？帮客人省钱啊。
阿仁帮客人省钱，帮刘德华省钱，告诉他，你去别的地方买什么，在这儿买什么，去别的地方买什么，这是一个救猫咪啊。来第五趴第五趴来到第10分钟啊，阿仁和黄警官见面，对吧？给另外一个校长啊，其实就是校长出殡。
嗯，这个呢隐藏一个含义就是。
阿仁的卧底身份现在只有一个知情人了，对吧？
然后呢，当然了，这场戏最重要的呃，这只是一个顺带手的一个小线索。最重要的是交代阿人的现状啊，继续交代阿人的现状。
阿仁的现状和困境，通过阿仁的抱怨交代的，记不记得？
三年又三年三年又三年是吧？都快十年了。
那交代完困境之后，顺便呢就把目标给扔出来了。
就是破了这个案子。
就退休。
陈哥要交货啊，只要人赃并获，咱们就退休，是主角的一个限定条件。实际上后面发现不是他的行动目标啊，不是整个电影的行动目标，是他目前的一个限制啊。
来第六盘14分钟。
刘警官的现状是什么呢？我们说阿人的现状。
讲完了，马上讲刘警官的现状，我们说双主角嘛，对不对？你不能偏不能偏呀，刘警官的现状马上交代啊。
警察局中的红人啊，小中层红人，而且呢上来就展现技能，记不记得主角上来如果要展现这个主角很厉害，会做一个技能展现。在这里做了没有啊？刘警官上来做的是技能展现，对不对啊？
你们回忆一下，有很多电影是这么做的啊，主角上来先用自己的小聪明办点事儿，制斗这个嫌疑犯啊，假冒律师。当然了，在这里假冒律师这件事情啊也是暗示了啊，这个刘警官啊比较擅长装。然后嘞。
这个同时给了一点点川帮小危机啊，你怎么知道这么多是吧？他当时有点没有反应过来。
来到第七趴。
第17分钟。
黄长官啊。
带领众人。
和琛哥第一次过大招啊，这场戏非常的长十几分钟，但是是一趴。因为他自己的那个部门的人不够用啊，掉了很多比其他部门的人，就包括呃刘警官。
呃，和琛哥第一次过招，双方的卧底啊都分别发挥了重要的作用。而且在这里非常重要的是，大家记一下啊，双方的卧底全都明牌给观众了。
称哥安排警察部的安插在警察部的卧底，就是刘警官。
然后黄警官安插在黑帮的卧底，就是阿仁全部名牌给观众。在这场戏里，通过这场斗智斗勇的戏，全部名牌给观众。
然后呢，最后两双打了一个平手，没有抓住琛哥，但是害得琛哥损失了几千万啊，货全部损失了。双方打了个平手，双方意识到对方在自己这里有卧底。
把这件事情明牌出来了，气氛开始紧张了，这才是整个故事最主要的目标啊，这是整个故事最主要的目标。究卧底。
然后但是记住啊，观众是名牌的。
观众自始至终是上帝视角知道所有的事情，这是这个电影的特点。给我记一下。后面我们再探讨。
来到第八拍32分钟啊，刚才这一大坨戏十几分钟就过去了。双方在警察局一间局促的局促的办公室对峙啊，这么重要的一场戏拍的非常不举气是吧？不大气。然后呢确认了整个剧本故事的主要目标。
确认的明显吗？这个故事。
都要发誓把对方的卧底揪出来，甚至用扑克牌的游戏打了个比喻，说会死人的，我们赌一下，谁先把。
太明显了，好吧，这场这个剧本故事的脉络。
极其明显，就是我要揪出对方的卧底，目标明牌了，那就开始。
开始啊，目标明牌了，那就开始上路。第二幕第九拍，第35分钟先展现了一下刘警官的这个爱情生活，爱情呀，这个装修新房子呀，对吧？未婚妻呀。
假面生活啊很假，活的很假。
然后。
正式接到任务，因为上一幕已经把任务任务明牌了啊，目标明牌了。但是呃明牌的时候明牌的是两方的那个那个琛哥和黄警官，不是我们两个主角，对吧？需要交给我们两个主角手里。
所以说展现了一下刘警官的假面生活以同时接到电话，他接到任务了，需要他开始调查对方卧底。琛哥告诉他，必须把这个卧底给我揪出来啊呃告诉他呃，然后他想到的一个方法就是对比这个资料啊，其实就是查身份证。
呃，这个第一招比较拙劣。
然后第十拍来到第38分钟啊。
阿仁也接到了黄警官的电话，但是他拒绝去跟黄警官还黄警官见面，对吧？因为他说你你那他卧底，我不能跟你见面了，你太危险了。实际上也也侧面反映出阿仁也意识到自己必须把卧底揪出来。
同时呢加了一坨呃可有可无的戏啊，这个我们后面在讨论，他去看了一个心理医生，在心理医生那里呢睡得很香，甚至向心理医生表明自己的身份啊。
嗯，这个呢我们要强调一下啊，这部电影如果单看第一部，有一些角色和戏份，实际上是飘离于主线以外的啊，这个我们待会儿再讨论。
来到第十一拍，第41分钟啊，刘警官接到上司的任务。
同时让他查警方的卧底是谁，警方的卧底就是他自己，对吧？所以说你看刘警官啊接到韩琛的任务，要查那个那个。
嗯，黑帮的卧底是谁？又接到上司的任务，要查警方的卧底是谁，实际他自己就是卧底啊，很受器重，他很受器重然后来到第十二趴啊。
42分钟，黑帮内部填表格啊，黑帮内部填表格。
同时呢这个呃阿仁呢帮傻强。
写字儿留了一个伏笔啊，这场戏是专门留伏笔用的，填表格。
啊，当然了也有个小细节啊，就是其实阿仁会写保镖的标，但是他假装不会写，因为他是黑社会嘛，不能不能真的，他开始写的是对的，金字牌实际上是对的嘛，后来又改成木字牌了啊，故意写错啊，说明这个这个阿仁还是比较细心的。
然后十三拍来到第43分钟。
刘警官和阿琛。
啊，也就琛哥啊，刘景刚和琛哥接头。
这场戏呢在一个电影院两个人街头啊，我们说在电影院做前后座接头也是一个致敬经典的一个场景啊，并不是这部戏发明的。
嗯。
嗯，这个街头这场戏除了推进刘警官调查以外。
这里有一个很重要的信息，后面会兑现的啊，就是刘警官发现琛哥不怎么信任自己了。
刘警官是村哥派到警察部的卧底。
春哥也是唯一的知情人，但是他发现琛哥不怎么信任自己了。
这个后面会兑现的，因为他要除掉陈哥。然后同时呢阿仁也开始行动了啊，阿仁跟踪琛哥到这里，想要看一看他跟谁接头。
但是呢未遂啊没有看到刘警官的脸，未遂了，只看到一个背影。
来到第十四盘，46分钟。
春哥约谈阿人。
告知下周进货，试探阿人啊试探阿人。
但是同时也推出了下周进货这件事情。第15拍来到第48分钟，刘警官正式推进他的目标啊，他开始他的调查工作。
危机很重，想抢先查到对方。因为确实呃他跟。
这个阿仁之间也是谁先查到对方，谁对方就得死嘛。
然后第1六拍51分钟啊，刘警官的爱情生活又来了。
刘警官的爱情生活这里呢是个点缀，因为刘警官每次执行新的任务，他肯定要有个着力点。所以说爱情生活再点一下。但是呢由于创作者觉得单点一个爱情生活太无聊了，就把刘警官的这个女友啊，这个未婚妻啊设定成了一个小说家啊，然后这个小说家写的这个主角就是个多面人啊。
用这个事情来暗喻一下刘警官的这个人生的价值观呀、抉择呀、走向呀，到底是不是个好人？这个大家记得吧。
有没有印象啊？
就是郑秀文这个角色啊，由于确实有点外挂，给他设定成了一个。
小说家啊用他创作的一个人物来暗喻一下刘警官的人生啊，以做一个平行的一个比喻，实际上是没有什么用啊，当然了，你这也有用啊。但是在这场戏里，最重要的是刘警官啊。
灵感来了灵感啊，也决定先跟踪黄警官。既然对方跟踪琛哥来查我，那我就跟踪黄警官来查对方啊。
同学们啊，我强调一下啊，我所有说的这场戏对主线没有什么用。
你们可以理解，就是对一个故事的主剧情没有什么用。
理论上，我们在写一个电影故事的时候，我希望所有的桥段和元素都和主剧情有关系，有用，有推进或者阻止的作用。
除此以外，其他的作用当然有。
明白吗？
假设你在这里拍一场刘警官突然拉肚子的戏。
然后花了3分钟拍他拉屎。
我会说这场戏跟主线剧情没有什么用，但你非要犟说老师这场戏反映了刘警官，因为这个因为对方有卧底上火了啊，一上火这个这个肠胃不舒服，所以拉肚子了，所以这场戏是有用的。
你要硬要这么解读，那你就算他有用吧。
你们明白我在说什么啊，所以我不是跟你们去讨论这场戏是不是真的有用，你当然可以理解为它有用。
但是它跟主线剧情作用不大，来到第17拍啊，53分钟。
17拍53分钟。上一场戏是刘景安决定跟踪黄警官啊，以其人之道还治其人之身啊。阿仁借口要去按摩啊。
偷偷溜出去跟黄长官会面，有一个小插曲，碰到了萧亚轩。
记不记得啊这场戏在这个。
呃，在网络上是流传比较广的一场戏啊，当年是没有短视频。如果有的话，这场戏在短视频里面会爆掉啊，起到一个巨大的宣传作用。但是这场戏。
啥又没有。
依然没有用啊依然没有用。
一些妈咪现在都搞。
我们接着说这场戏啊，阿仁啊去跟黄长官见面啊，刘警官呢就派手下去去跟踪啊，同时知道了黄长官的位置之后，报告给琛哥啊，让琛哥去赌。
然后在这场戏里面啊，琛哥派人把黄警官堵在了大楼里，黄警官被杀，然后傻强也在这里死掉了。阿仁呢幸运的躲过了一劫啊，躲过了一劫。由于知道他偷偷溜走的人都死了，所以他躲过了一劫。
然后来到第十八拍，68分钟在警察局里。
这时候呢我们的主角刘警官已经完全掌握了局面。刘警官把卧底唯一的联系人黄警官。
借琛哥的手杀了之后，取得了一个什么？
取得了一个阶段性的胜利。
对吧在我们的故事当中，我们叫虚假的胜利。但是同学们一定不要字面的去理解虚假这种东西啊，实际上就是一个阶段性的一个胜利。
他以为胜利了，在这里在68场这里啊有非常明确的一个展现，就是刘警官非常的得意自己完全掌握了局面。但是。
发现自己失去了琛歌的信任。
也就是说他除掉了。
他除掉除掉了阿仁唯一的联络人，他以为这个卧底被他干掉了。
但是他自己的联络人也是唯一的联络人，琛哥实际上也摇摇欲坠了，你不搭理他。
于是新的危机就产生了。
然后呢，他开始用黄警官的手机去呼叫这个阿仁去试探对方。
然后来到第1九趴72分钟。
刘警官和阿仁快速的。
有点快速的。
达成了合作意愿啊，相对有点快速的就达成了合作意愿。
栽赃阿强就是卧底。
啊，栽赃阿强就是卧底，很顺利的阿仁很顺利的就获取了信任。
也很顺利的引诱春哥去货仓。也就是说，刘警官跟阿仁这两个人第一次合作非常顺利。栽他阿强是卧底，也非常顺利呃获得春哥信任，非常顺利。然后引诱春哥去货仓，非常春哥也上套了啊。因为以为阿强是。
卧底嘛？卧底又知道阿强又知道货仓的位置，所以引诱乘哥去货仓看一看。
然后刘警官呢呃在警察部也配合这件事情，两个人呢就用摩斯密码沟通啊。之前这个刘警官不会摩斯密码，在这里就会了学会了啊，两个人用摩斯密码沟通。
警方呢把琛哥堵在了货舱里。然后由于刘警官也熟悉这里的环境啊，通过这个这个这个呃一一番骚操作啊，把称哥单独堵在了一个地方，自己亲手除掉了琛哥。
解决了自己的危机啊，主角解决了自己最大的危机。嗯，我们说在故事终点那里，他解他解决了卧底那边来的威胁。在这里呢又解决了呃自己这边的威险。
然后第20part来到第80分钟，两个人主角终于正式见面了，之前就见过面啊，终于正式以坦诚的身份见面了。
原来是老朋友嘛，对吧？老相识。
嗯，这个。
阿仁呢。
发现刘警官其实是内鬼。本来阿仁是来恢复身份的啊，但是在这里他发现刘警官其实就是那个内鬼，因为之前有埋伏笔啊，在这个档案袋上写字这个伏笔阿仁逃走了。
逃走了以后，刘警官也迅速马上意识到对方识破了自己，在这里给戏都给的特别快啊，这是港版的一个问题。二仁逃走之后，刘警官通过对方翻看自己的东西，发现自己识破自己了，于是立刻删掉了对方唯一的身份信息。
然后第21盘84分钟。
阿仁走投无路，对吧？因为他唯一的联络人死了，现在的联络人，这个刘警官是内鬼，而且刘警官现在春风得意，他完全没有招了啊，进入这个这个这个灵魂黑夜了吧。阿仁进入灵魂黑夜了啊。但是这个灵魂黑夜啊做的确实是没有什么仪式感，也没有受伤，也没有下大雨啊，啥事儿没有。
反而跑去了心理医生那里那里整理思路啊，想办法号称他自己明说的啊，我来这儿整理一下思路，在灵魂黑夜的地方啊，火烧屁股了。当然这个灵魂黑夜没有用火，也没有用水，确实是比较失败。
但是火烧屁股了，还要泡妞。
这场戏极其失败。
你们任何人以后在如果你们在创作的时候，敢在灵魂黑夜里给我泡妞，那绝对我不可能允许的。
好吗？
因为他在这里去跟心理医生表白去了，而且那个陈慧雷还跟他反表白。
简直胡来啊简直胡来。
然后来到第2十2拍啊，22拍87分钟。
刘警官家里啊也被寄来了录音证据。
他的家庭破裂了啊，爱情破裂了。当然这是来自阿仁的反击啊，阿仁呢在琛哥那里发现了刘警官的电话录音。
既来这里，既把刘警官的家庭搞破裂了，又把刘警官的这个。
又把刘警官的这个事业啊逼到。因为刘警官在乎最在乎的就是自己在警察部的这个事业嘛，对吧？他杀掉那么多人，维护的是自己这个事业，对吧？他想继续做警察，嗯，这是刘警官的。
灵魂黑夜。
刚才说了双主角嘛，一个枝头的两朵花，这个故事的两个主角，所以同时进入灵魂黑夜，明白吗？这点上还是工整的。
然后两个人同时进入灵魂黑夜之后，两个人约了个谈判啊，真的看出这个电影啊确实在这个制作成本上捉襟见肘是吧？在灵魂黑夜准备绝堤大反击，两个人约了个谈判。
故事进入第四幕。
第23拍啊，来到第90分钟。
著名的。
天台大决战啊，著名的名场面，天台大决战是吧？对不起啊，我想做个好人是吧？对不起，我是警察，谁知道是吧？著名的天台大决战啊，非常小成本的大决战。
然后这个大决战没有什么场面啊，就很短暂啊，很短暂，一两分钟就结束了。就是整个故事的最高潮。当然了，当年看的时候没有觉得这里呃这个掉链子啊，因为这场戏还是很酷的呃，从配乐从运镜，因为去了天台那个运境就比较自由了，对吧？天空是广阔的呀。
这个这个运镜，再加上这个梁朝伟老师这个这这精致精湛的演技。
呃，当然了，华哥也不怎么掉链子是吧？两个人的演技呃，在这场戏里面。
还是还是呃绝对扛下了这个大场面啊，绝对扛下了这个大场面。
来到第24拍。
92分钟啊。
两个人的谈判啊被这个莫名其妙的东莞仔给打断了啊。嗯，由于解决不了，就机械将神来了的东莞仔。
这个东莞仔呢呃。
也是这个陈哥的卧底，但是不受重用是吧？然后把二仁给打死了，把我们的呃一个主角给打死了。然后第25拍来到94分钟，电梯里面的枪声再次响起，对吧？因为刘警官不希望有任何人知道他是卧底，你现在又拖出来一个东莞仔，所以这个东莞仔也必然被做掉啊，东棺仔也必然被干掉。
所以把东干来干掉了。
第26拍95分钟啊，刘警官。
干掉这么多人，竟然还是这个资料早就寄到了这个警察库啊。呃人家知道他是卧底了，把他带走了。
5分钟的第四幕。
第四幕5分钟啊，草草收尾，这部电影一共95分钟结束。
呃，坦白说啊，这部电影它肯定有它制作成本方面啊带来的一些限制，确实没有展开啊，没有敞开，不是说水平不行啊，确实是这个这个可能钱都花在演员身上了啊。但是当时这部戏其实演员也没有花太多的钱。因为200几年的时候啊。
正好赶上了啊。
就是。
加入WTO以后啊。
香港电影受到的冲击非常大。
同学们可能不知道啊，这部电影是2002年的，我们中国是2001年加入WTO的，加入WTO之后，其实当时有一个非常重要的一件一个变化，就是可以引进好莱坞片子了。
可以大张旗鼓的引进好莱坞片子了。因为在这之前咱们看到最酷的东西啊，其实就是香港片，觉得老酷了。但是后突然可以看那个了。所以说香港电影在那几年啊受到的冲击非常大啊。
来。
这部电影啊我们客观讲。
绝对是经典绝对是里程碑啊绝对是经典，绝对是里程碑。但是他拍的时候呢也不知道自己对身后的这个电影史影响这么大啊，所以说他当时确实有一些地方能省则省啊啊，这个剧本也被很多国家买垛翻拍了。其中美国版那可是那个这个迪卡普利奥演的。
是吧那是很厉害的啊。来这部电影有很多名场面，我们一起看一下啊。
来看一下，我们说这个音响店名场面，我们看一下吧，那谁。
各位。
我们啊，我喜欢试下可不可。
外喇吧没个我们好干手。
呢部啦港产胆机皮岭嘢。
千两万的头跑线等个就十几码那招火。
高音甜中音准低音劲，等佢讲晒通透了啫。
来管他啊。
是谁？
在敲打我窗点。
是谁太太多？
在了动这样放我家里前。
那一段。
被遗忘的时光。
喂，小丽姐。
听啲狗嘢呢，你酒的。
是谁等在敲打我窗？
很看不起啊。
。
O这大个椒O.
多谢晒我嗯，喂，而家个长威有人啊，有人噶，唔该喂，你个死仔啊，我叫你帮我睇住，你又同我倒米咁你喇叭系买得贵啊嘛，咁我都唔买得贵，我点有钱交保护费俾你班大佬啊，你又试下唔好交啊。
喂就C啊，这系用几啊喂四千0几嘛你这系用几日，你关注边啊？好，我们说啊这场戏嗯。
名场面之一啊。
跟大家说一个小插曲啊，这部电影是2002年，也是我在大学期间啊，我在上大学的时候，勤工俭写做了一有一个很重要的一个收入来源啊，就是去。
现在这个行业好像不太受待见啊，这个行业好像一直也不太受待见。
就去卖黄牛票啊，这个大家不要去咬样说呀啊，是错误的是错误的。
但是呢我在上大学的时候啊，需要转学杂费，转生活费。所以这个我经常去去去去去去那个虹沟体育场，上海体育场去卖黄牛票啊。
具体流程就不说了，但跟大家说一个细节啊，在当年能开演唱会的咖位。
就必须得是有咖位的人才能开演唱会。同学们。
就是在当年啊能开演唱会的歌手都是很厉害的。比如说。
张学友啊，这个周杰伦这种才能开演唱会，因为开演唱会确实是需要有票房保证的。在当年啊现在不一样的，像当年不是的。
但是蔡琴因为这部电影。
就从一个不能开演唱会的歌手变成了一个瞬间开演唱会的歌手，瞬间变成了一个拥有演唱会级别商业价值的歌手。就这部电影火了之后，蔡琴马上来内地开始开演唱会，连着开了好几年。
这部电影让蔡琴赚了很多钱。
当然了，这只是个小细节啊，我们给大家说一下这场戏啊，我们来学习一下这场戏啊，两个主角第一次正式相遇，那我们就用。
两个人共同的一个爱好，听音乐，去做两个人的一个共通点，对吧？相遇系嘛，然后做共通点，由于这两个人后面是1个PK的关系，所以我们做了一个变化转折，就上来人格阿仁看起来是比刘警官更懂去教他，最后发现刘警官奇高一招，人家深藏不漏。
人家明明很懂，但是不吭声。
对吧阿仁还傻呵呵的去帮人家。
明白吗？所以说这场戏主要是做这个作用。
当然了，顺便把阿人的身份也交代了一下，他是收保护费的。
这场戏啊名场面。
再看一下，在互联网上流团很广的。
琛哥的警察局吃播戏。
呃上个。
刘松啊那么大你说。
可查清楚啊呢两条嘅沙度吹风啫咗你咁忙好耐开啦，你中意随得听日啦。
不玩了。
我买力唔使，我唔好意思啊真阿心过嚟今晚跌咗几千蚊。
18了了。
说句我啊。
来干工我啊。
到了没有古宅。
有两个傻佬喺医院度等换肾，大个神啊得一个两个人嚟玩个游戏。
一人将张牌摆对方嘅袋边个估到对方摆咩牌落自己嘅袋嗰个就算赢。
你听我台度里面白。
我的乡镇还。
严感。
好了，受伤点了，大家啊。
他们给我不也听过。
一个徐小姐会生意。
你是谁。
你给人家帮你混掉同学戏来那手面。
走。
好，这场戏啊这场戏首先这个这个在这个影视作品的吃吃饭系里面嗯有一号啊，呃这是一个看它的一个呃原因。第二个原因呢，这场戏是呃确立了目标啊，确立了。
整个故事的目标就是要揪出对方的卧底啊，要非常明确的喊出来了啊，所以是第一幕的一个结尾戏。
来很多同学在在讨论说，为什么吃播戏是代表什么啊，代表什么贪婪这我觉得倒是不用解读的那么深啊，不是说我们要塑造一个人贪婪，就让他吃东西，并不是这样。
呃，实际上啊是。
我认为啊。
我认为在故事里面加上吃东西的戏啊是。
是很容易让一个戏更快的接地气的。
我在课上其实讲过修改剧本的时候，你要检查一下你的戏里面有没有无感，有没有吃东西，有没有味道，有没有听觉，有没有这些东西，对吧？
我是比较鼓励在塑造角色或者是在戏的时候加上点吃东西的戏啊，你就像那个那个高启强爱吃这个猪脚饭是吧？呃，这个大家印象很深啊，因为这个呃嗅觉啊、视觉呀、触味觉啊，这些东西打通以后啊，更容易让观众产生比较强烈的印象。
所以说呃倒不是说为了塑造一个人物贪婪了，不贪婪的角色也可以吃吃东西。
大家回想一下啊，影视作品当中的。
经典吃戏，你像这个马大帅里面有蛮多吃戏的是吧？另外那个落叶归根是吧？
然后还有这个民工里面哈，那个那个当年有一个神剧啊，我不知道你们有没有印象，当年有个神剧叫民工啊，拍的非常之好啊。
也是很粗糙，非常小成本。
嗯，那个呃那个大灯非常不讲究啊，镜头也非常不讲究，但是演员拍的是非常好啊，这是关于吃戏啊，实际上是我是比较鼓励的。
但是也不用过度解读嗯。
再说一下啊，这部戏像这场戏啊，在后面呃导演他们复盘的时候啊，实际上这这场戏就是他们自己也知道这是一场很重要的戏，也呢是确实是受到经费限制，可能也没有什么场地拍。实际上这场戏也有别的方案啊，就这场。
黄警官和琛哥对峙谈判这场戏实际也有别的方案。
为了交代两个人是老朋友，然后是老相识了，然后又交代两个人剑拔弩章。实际上他们还设计了一场，就是琛哥和和黄警官一边下围棋，一边聊这个事儿。
这么一种拍法。
这场戏也有其他方案，有一个方案是琛哥和黄警官下围棋。同学们也可以理解啊，那个装逼范儿，然后你下一个字儿，我下一个字儿，然后说你在我这有卧底，对吧？我这有我这种这种装逼范儿啊，比较直接的比较直接的一种一种比喻啊嗯这个形象化的一个比喻，但实际上确实是不如。
呃，现在这个呈现效果啊。
我们再看一个名场面啊，我们刚才说过的那个放在现在的短视频这个领域很容易火的一场戏啊。
萧亚轩这场。
那个楼呀很帅。
哪个小小雨。
好短等我老公车，拜拜拜。
考了把谁啊嗯。
妈咪现在都搞错。
咪搞错好，这场戏啊我们说呃如果是放在新媒体平台啊，票房宣传的话会起到非常大的作用啊。嗯，很多同学可能不了解啊，现在电影剪出来像这种呃单场素材容易爆火的这种素材。
在新媒体平台做投放。
单位儿。
1亿。
同学们。
在新媒体平台，现在对单个素材的投放。
过亿。
就是投聚合投铅川啊，过亿。
明白吗？
所以千万不要小看啊。
千万不要小看现在电影的宣传手段，有很多手段，其实还有很多很多的宣传方法，你们都想不到啊。如果是在现在拍这个电影这场戏我绝对不会说这是一场飞戏，因为这场戏会在新媒体平台传播的很好，它会非常有用。
他会直接给这个电影带来几个亿的票房啊，这个当然不是我们编剧该关心的事情啊，嗯大家就了解一下就行了啊，但是这场戏我们可以看到一个什么啊。
看到一件事情就是萧亚轩跟这个梁朝伟对戏啊。
竟然不落下风哎。
我们说萧亚轩不光是这个这个唱唱歌跳舞，谈恋爱方面都都都很有很有天分，演戏也是非常有天分。萧亚轩把一个女人的局促对吧？错愕。
局促掩盖是吧？然后还有点念旧情。
整个方方面面拿捏的十分到位啊，这是一个非常有天赋的演员啊，非常有天赋来。
再来看一下啊，这个戏的最最高潮啊，天台大决战解决问题的一场戏，这个必看好不好？
我一个眼泪没必大。
感不谢弟们。
算差的太远了嘛。
不要给我我。
定备给不了。
我也请不得干。
我而家想干饭就好人。
怎发更高了。
他被备了9眼。
你在冤我谁呀？
退去。
乖差呀，别急。
你啊睇下何心卧卧底先佢喺我手度有咩事翻差馆先讲放大上即个放大上我报咗警啊，我点解要信你啊，你唔使信我。
提高点。
底给我。
。
走。
那警察部一帆风顺。
全部有更作外省。
再见哦，大家注心体。
一个三个谁做。
有的有带举吗。
你跟不同，我这个咁到点露给跟露没。
可连家没都唔傻了我。
晚上我搞点晒噶，上呢有冇跟你。
找来。
这位就军头。
其实我就好醒嘅，佢首唔歌唔识睇啫。
嗯。
菜呀。
好啊。
这个版本啊是刘德华继续混下去了啊，但是在咱们内地的平台上上的版本是刘德华下楼的时候被抓了啊。因为这个坏人必须有坏人必须得到惩罚，是一条刚线啊，是不能逾越的，明白吗？待会我们再讨论这两个结局。
大家记住啊，在内地的版本，刘德华下楼的时候是被抓了。因为之前说了，陈永仁在来之前已经报警了。
我们来先来研究第一个事情。来我们先来研究这个电影的第一事情。这个故事的主角当然是双主角，对吧？一个枝头的两朵花，但严格上来说。
谁是主角？
我们先先不说答案，再来思考这个。
主线目标是谁的？整个故事的中前期的主线目标是谁在一直出招，谁在推进目标进行刘德华。
整个故事的中前期是刘德华一直在推进目标前进，一直在捉阿人。
但是。
绝地反击是谁的？绝地反击是阿人。
最后这个天台大决战是梁朝伟主导。
只有这一场戏只有这一个环节是梁朝伟主导的。但是啊我们也不能说梁朝伟一点主动力都没有啊，但是是刘德华在主导整个事情。
他先查卧底，他先出招，他先跟踪黄色，他做掉黄色，他在做掉撑哥，然后他再想做掉梁朝伟。
所以说整个故事的。
大部分时候，刘警官压的更多一些。
主动性更大一些。
我们说这是第一个问题，我们可以探讨。
第二个问题很显而易见的，刘德华基本上来说是个反派。
阿仁是个正面角色，是按照一个主角的人品构成设计的。
刘德华呢相对复杂，但是本质上是个坏人，因为他做掉。
黄警官和做掉撑歌杀人不眨眼，好吧，这是第二个我们思考的问题。第一个思考的问题是。
主主线任务谁主导？第二个思考的问题是谁是好人，谁是坏人，这些都要思考。
判断谁是主角，我们这些都是思考的嘛。因为谁是好人，谁是坏人，涉及到一个问题啊，你共情谁嘞？有些同学说我有那么一瞬间，实际上希望刘德华作为一个好人，因为他如果彻底摆脱陈哥，他有可能真的是个好警察，有没有人共情过刘德华。
共情过刘警官这个角色呢，有的我看一下。
因为你想啊他选择到警察部当卧底，实际上。
也不是说。
他自愿的。
他也被迫嘛，他也有小把柄在人手里。
所以理论上啊会有相当一部分观众也是会去共情这个所谓的反派的。
他也不容易，但是他杀人了，这个是救不了。
所以你看共情这个东西啊各各有千秋。
我们再来看人物弧线，我们说阿仁是没有人物弧线的对吧？他自始至终从第一次见心理医生啊，都坚信坚称自己是一个警察。
自己要回到警队啊，自己受够了卧底生活。
虽然尽职尽责，但是呢阿仁。
都没有。
动要过去了。
一直啊没有动摇，没有人欠。
我们说刘警官有人物弧线吗？
刘警官说，以前我没得选，现在我想做个好人，这是人物互线吗？我以其实也没有，他自始至终也就是趋利避害啊，他并没有真正的说从坏人变成好人。如果刘警官开始的时候被迫做卧底。
他后来想办法除掉琛哥，真的是为了做一个好警察，他没有害别人，只是把琛哥除掉。那么刘警官就真的是个主角。
所以说从人物弧线这里啊，两个人基本上。
也是平手啊，刘警官没有什么便宜。
那综合下来。
综合共情的角度，好人坏人的角度，人无间的角度，这个这个主导主线剧情的角度。因为我们说主线剧情就是比赛，谁先揪出对方卧底嘛？
这在香港电影里面很多的啊，我们叫双雄戏。双雄戏啊实际上就是双主。
但你说双主角吧，总有。
总有。
你总有偏向哪一方嘛？
所以说这个电影关于主角是谁啊，只是抛出来让大家讨论一下，不需要有答案就是。
就是双主角，双雄对决。
这种类型的故事其实挺多的，不需要严格的去分。因为为什么呢？因为确实有的时候是刘德华主导，但有的环节呢又交给梁朝伟主导。
那从这个电影啊，我们学一学点东西啊。
给我学一个东西，课后留个作业，先留第一个作业。
就这个电影我们在第一次看的时候，他的紧张气氛制造的是很足的。
黄色儿是吧，掉落天台是吧？然后那个影院跟踪是吧？刘德华步步紧逼，要查这个阿仁，然后阿仁和阿仁在琛哥那里给黄色儿报告情报啊，手上的石膏被砸开。我们说这个故事的紧张感很足。
悬疑感很足。
但是同学们有没有？
再次给我深刻的理解一下嘛叫悬疑。
悬疑是不是让观众啥也不知道啊，同学们再给我理解一下，你们以前给我写悬疑故事的时候，永远是给我弄一个故弄玄虚的东西，然后让观众啥也不知道去猜。
但是在这个电影你给我看一下。
谁是卧底？
这两个人刘德华是这边的卧底，梁朝伟是这边的卧底，恨不得一开始就告诉观众。
大家有没有发现你让观众知道，但是角色知不道是吧？梁朝伟不知道那边的事情，刘德华不知道那边的事情，观众反而更着急。
能不能理解我为什么天天苦口婆心的让你们写信息差，而且我永远让你们练的是观众知情，角色不知情。
因为这种才是最主流。
你们喜欢写的那种观众也不知道，主角也不知道，大家两眼一摸黑那种所谓悬疑。我跟你说真的特别累，吃力不讨好，而且你也写不好。
给我写这一种。
咱们作为一个。
从业人员啊，我我坦白跟大家讲，咱们作为一个创作者，作为从业人员。
学会这一招就行。
这就是所谓的信息差啊，这就是咱们给大家说的信息差带来的悬念。在这部电影里面体现的那叫一个淋漓尽致，通篇都是观众知道，角策不知道。
如果。
你听我的。
你回去心里装着这件事情，再把这个电影看一遍，你就会发现啊。
咦。
还挺好用的。
都哪些戏是根据这件事情让观众给着急了。
我们来再来看一下这部电影还有哪些地方是可以把玩玩位的啊。
我们说。
在买音响这场戏里，刷完卡收据写的日期是2002年11月28号是吧？
然后在最后我们说二人死了这场戏。
他墓碑上的日期是。
11月27号。
比那个还早一天。
然后啊我看。
网上有很多人去解读说整个电影就是一个轮回，因为他死在了。
见到刘德华的前一天。
在这里啊跟大家说一下，所有关于这些小bug啊，小东西啊，不必去在意啊。因为这个戏拍的时候肯定不是2002年嘛，但是他预计在会在2002年上线，所以他就写了一下关于2002年的一些日期是吧？他就瞎写了一些关于2002年的日。
拍戏的时候会经常遇到啊经常遇到，确实是不必过度解读。
谈不上会在暗喻，这是一个轮回啊。但是我们说呃呃这个陈永仁和这个刘警官两个人在警校的警号是倒过来的，证明这两个人是同一个人的镜面。我们说这种设计啊，有可能确实是写剧本的时候就这么写的。
明白吗？
就两个人的井号这件事情，两个人的井号数字是颠倒过来的。
这个确实有可能是写的时候觉得哎，反正我要写镜面主角，这两个角色是同一个针上的两朵花，那我就把他们的井号。
数字调一调顺序，这个当然是ok的。
好吧。
然后还有讨论比较多的啊，就是关于心理医生这个这个陈慧琳和萧亚轩，我明确的表达一下我的观点啊，确实没有必要。
特别是在灵魂黑夜还跑去跟心理医生去去去表个白啊。心理医生说我也喜欢你很久了，然后两个人表白拥抱这种戏不用过度解读，说这是什么作者的一个深意，什么什么就是失误了。就是我跟你说，就是老板安插的女演员太多了，消化不了。
这么说够直白吗？
关于其他bug啊，比如说这个。
黄警官被堵在天台对吧？为什么不躲起来啊，为什么不躲在其他楼层是吧？就那几个人往上堵一栋大楼实际是堵不住的啊，躲不了，这个是个bug啊。我们说一个电影不可能没有bug啊，这是强调一下，不管是什么电影，它不可能没有bug。我之前拉片的时候跟你们说过啊。
关于黄警官为什么没躲掉？当然你可以解释。哎呀，一被一堵懵逼了啊，就这么解释过去，当然也可以啊。
呃，再一就是为什么选择今天杀黄警官，对吧？黄警官作为一个普通的警官。
实际上你想杀他哪天都行，对吧？为什么今天要去杀他，实际是没有必要的，因为哪天杀他都可以逼问他卧底是谁，没有必要，非得今天杀啊，包括这两个人的卧底身份，对吧？他们俩那个刘德华都可以远程给所有的操控基站，给所有人的手机发信息。
而且上来就可以通过手机定位。实际上这个茶卧底啊没有那么复杂啊，这都是这种戏常见的bug，其实没有办法。
啊，包括这个傻强是卧底啊，傻强是卧底这个这件事情吧。
呃，给的太快了，确实是给的太快了。傻强是握底这个事情。
琛哥是如何从最信任傻强变成坚信傻傻强就是卧底。
到底给了哪些证据啊，到底给了哪些证据，这个嗯也确实是。
这个这个。
几句话带过啊，非常草率。然后再就是梁朝伟发现，就阿里人发现刘警官是卧底啊，他为什么第一时间选择逃跑？
因为在警察局其实是最安全的啊。
他为什么选择逃跑？这个事情吧，也确实是。
也没搞清楚啊也没搞清楚。
然后这个。
呃，刘警官的那个录音啊，刘警官除掉称歌啊，又除除掉黄警官，除掉称歌呃，，而且马上就要除掉梁朝伟的资料。
他的电话录音突然机械降神也是有点突兀啊，也是有点突兀的。
在这里呢是也确实出现了。
嗯，一个片子到了后期啊这个非常的仓促，非常的乏力。
我们说这是都是剧情一些。
呃，相对有bug的地方啊，我们能找到，但是呃并不是代表我们在吐槽这个电影，呃，而是表示我们如果写的时候啊，怎么去纠正这些问题，怎么去避免这些问题，或者是说怎么去尽量避免这些问题。因为我们发现这部电影啊短短的90分钟啊，短短的90分钟的一部电影。其实正片不到90分。
他的。
第三目和第四目极其短，我刚才说了啊，第四目啊第四目只有5分钟。
第四幕解决问题就是天台聊天。
就5分钟天台聊天。
电梯枪战啊，电梯枪战甚至都拍了一半，没怎么拍。
整个第四幕非常的短促啊，很多东西都没有展开。包括。
包括为什么会留着这些炸弹，这些人还有什么？
这个斗法还能出什么招？
嗯，实际上确实是没有那个没有展开这部戏的bug还是有一些的。
但是。
我想说的是，这部戏最大的bug就是一个黑帮。
竟然能找出一帮小弟。
考上公务员。
能考上公务员，他还用刀黑社会吗？很小说很漫画的一个设定啊，其实就是很小说很漫画的一个设定。来留下几个思考，两个思考题。
第一个思考题。
就是这个结局到底怎么写？如果是你你到底怎么写？
比如说阿仁死不死。
刘景湾是不是？
刘警官是不是被抓？刘警官要不要穿帮，对吧？
这个结局如果你写你怎么写，这是第一个思考题。
回去思考一下，甚至写一写，好吧，这是第一个题啊，结局如果让你写，你怎么写？因为这个结局有好几个版本，确实有好几个版本啊，为了为了内地上映。
第二。
第四幕。
给我扩充10分钟。
你怎么写？我们说现在整个整个正片啊不到90分钟。
第四幕才5分钟严重不足。
不过瘾。
其实是不过瘾的啊，绝对不过瘾啊。
如何扩充10分钟？
然后这部戏啊我们能学到的东西啊，最重要的东西这部戏我们学会双雄戏怎么写。
看起来是两个主角。我们说在这部戏里面的双主角真的是镜面主角啊，这两部分人一黑一白，黑的是白的那边的卧底，白的是黑的那边的卧底。我们说这两个人的镜子啊照的不要不要的啊，镜子的两面在这部电影里面体现的淋漓尽致。
在这种情况下，双雄序应该怎么写呢？
在有信心的情况下啊，这部电影就是非常有信心。因为他请了刘德华加梁朝伟，这在当年也是神仙组合啊。
他在有神仙组合这两张牌的情况下，他把两个主角当一个主角写。
也就是说，在中前部主线目标是刘德华的，他完全没有在意。
到了后期啊，换成梁朝伟主导剧情。
无缝衔接。
我们说这种情况是在你有信心让主让观众同时接受，或者是同时。
在两个角色身上都入戏的情况下，你才敢。
否则很容易掉链子。我给大家举一个电视剧啊。
有一部电视剧。
叫什么？我忘了，反正是陈道明老师和台湾那个演员叫什么来着？演刘邦和项羽也是双雄戏啊，他的那个电视剧结构用双雄的结构去拍的。
但是他切换的时候啊。
就很容易让观众啊损失掉一半。
其实是有风险的啊，在双雄戏里面啊。
如果有信心，可以把两个主角当一个来写，你在心里就以为他俩是一个人写这种电影的诀窍就是你虽然写两个角色，但是你在排布我们说排布你的启程转合以及排布你的每个节拍的时候。
你你脑子里面想的是谁往前推都可以。
当一个角色去写。
这是我们在这部电影当中能学到的最宝贵的东西。
他不在意是谁推这两个谁推都可以。因为在创作者当中，他俩是一个人。
但你如果没有信息。
最好还是想办法以梁朝伟为主线行。
也就是说，上来他。
的主动性，他的危机最大，他快要穿帮了，他时间来不及了，他必须得完成了。
然后他面临这些问题怎么解决，用他的视角多一些。
肯定还是跟着那个三观正的人走比好。
这是我们这部电影。
需要学的最多的东西。
还是那句话，客观的看一部电影，不要捧砂啊，不要看一部电影就给他封尘，永远有他的问题啊，时间上制作周期上我跟大家讲啊，这部电影可能就拍了20天。
现在的电影那个那个风神光集训就一年半是吧？拍了35年，明白吗？
而且人家香港人，我跟你说，人家下班回家睡觉的，不是我们拍电影，咱们拍电影，咱们拍电影是集中在一起，先什么封闭训练6个月，舞蹈训练3个月，起马训练三个月，对吧？然后封闭在一起好几年，不能回家住宾馆。
这个电影我跟你说，人家是早上去拍，晚上回家吃饭。
在香港拍电影是晚上人回家的。
你看坐地铁回家了，下班以后。
才拍了20天。
他们的小成本，他们实际上是很。
很这个很懂省钱的啊，我们看过的很多经典电影，有的都是一个礼拜拍完的。比如说整蛊之王什么的，十天8天的就拍完了。
确实啊我们非常尊敬老老一代香港电影的的实力，包括对世界的影响力，包括老一代的香港演员啊也非常的敬业。但是我还是那句话是时势造英雄。我。
接触过的很多香港演员啊，相当一部分香港演员非常好，当然也有不好的啊。好的香港演员非常敬业。但是还是那句话，时势造英雄啊，你不要把英国搞反了，你说是因为有一批好的演员造就了当年的繁荣，不是啊，还是时势造英雄，我们非常尊重他们，但是我们也客观的啊看到一部片子。
他在相对资金和时间捉襟见肘的情况下，确实有很多地方也没有展开啊。
呃，留给大家去思考，自己去写，想办法，你会怎么展开，好吧。
那咱们这节这节课啊就上到这儿。